Realmente he estado esperando al lado del telefono
por una llamada de TED hace años.
Y de hecho, en el año 2000, estaba listo para hablar de eBay... pero no hubo llamada.
En el 2003 estaba listo para dar una charla
sobre la Fundación Skoll y el emprendimiento social. No hubo llamada.
En el 2004 fundé Participant Productions
y tuvimos un muy buen primer año, y no hubo llamada.
Y finalmente recibo la llamada el año pasado,
y me toca hablar después de J.J. Abrams.
(Risas)
Tienes un cruel sentido del humor, TED.
Cuando me mudé a Hollywood desde Silicon Valley,
tenía algunas dudas.
Pero me di cuenta que había algunas ventajas por estar en Hollywood.
(Risas)
Y, de hecho, algunas ventajas a ser dueño de tu propia empresa de medios.
Y también me di cuenta que Hollywood y Silicon Valley
tienen mucho más en común de lo que yo hubiese soñado.
Hollywood tiene sus símbolos sexuales, y el valle tiene sus simbolos sexuales.
(Risas)
Hollywood tiene sus rivalidades, y el Valle tiene sus rivalidades.
Hollywood se reúne alrededor de mesas de poder,
y el Valle se reúne alrededor de mesas de poder,
De modo que resultó que había mucho más en común,
que yo --- que yo hubiese soñado.
Pero estoy aquí para contar una historia.
Y parte de ella es una historia personal. Cuando Chris me invitó a hablar,
él dijo "la gente piensa de tí como -- un poco como un enigma,
y quieren saber que es lo que te motiva".
Y lo que realmente me motiva - es una visión del futuro
que yo creo que todos compartimos.
Es un mundo de paz y prosperidad y sustentabilidad.
Y cuando nosotros -- cuando escuchamos muchas de las presentaciones,
durante el último par de días,
Ed Wilson y las imágenes de James Nachtwey,
creo que todos nos dimos cuenta de cuanto tenemos por hacer
para llegar a esa nueva version de la humanidad
que me gusta llamar "Humanidad 2.0".
y también es algo que vive en cada uno de nosotros,
para cerrar lo que yo creo son las
dos grandes calamidades en el mundo de hoy.
Una es la brecha en oportunidad --
esta brecha que el Presidente Clinton anoche
llamo despareja, injusta e insostenible --
y de allí surge la pobreza y el analfabetismo y la enfermedad
y todos esos males que vemos alrededor nuestro.
Pero tal vez la otra brecha mayor es la que llamamos la brecha de esperanza.
Y alguien en algún momento tuvo esta muy mala idea
que un individuo común no podía hacer una diferencia en este mundo.
Y yo creo que eso es una cosa horrible.
Y así el Capìtulo Uno realmente comienza hoy, con todos nosotros,
porque en cada uno de nosotros esta el poder para
nivelar esas brechas de oportunidad y cerrar las brechas de esperanza.
Y si los hombres y mujeres de TED
no pueden hacer una diferencia en este mundo, no se quién puede.
Y para mi, mucho de esto comenzo cuando era mas joven
y mi family iba de camping al norte del estado de Nueva York.
Y realmente no habia mucho para hacer allì en el verano
excepto ser golpeado por mi hermana o leer libros.
Y así solìa leer autores como James Michener
y James Clavell y Ayn Rand.
Y sus historias hicieron que el mundo pareciera lugar muy pequeño
e interconectado.
Y me di cuenta que si podía escribir historias
que eran sobre este mundo como un lugar pequeño e interconectado,
entonces tal vez pudiera conseguir que la gente se interesara en los temas
que nos afectaban a todos. Y tal vez involucrarlos para que hagan una diferencia.
No creia que fuese necesariamente la mejor manera de ganarse la vida,
por lo que decidí tomar el camino para ser financieramente independiente,
y así poder escribir esas historias lo mas rápido que pudiese.
Entonces tuve un llamado de atención cuando tenía 14 años.
Y mi papa llegó a casa un día
y anunció que tenía cancer y que la cosa se veía muy mal.
Y lo que dijo fue, el no tenia tanto miedo de morir,
pero de que no había hecho las cosas que quería hacer con su vida.
Y, golpeemos sobre madera, el sigue vivo hoy, muchos años después.
Pero para un joven eso me causó una profunda impresión:
que uno nunca sabe cuanto tiempo tiene realmente.
De modo que salí apurado. Estudié ingeniería.
Comencé un par de negocios
que pensé serían mi pasaje a la libertad financiera.
Uno de esos negocios era un alquiler de computadoras
llamado Micros on the Move (Micros en Movimiento),
que tenía un muy buen nombre,
porque la gente se las robaba.
(Risas)
Asi me dí cuenta que necesitaba aprender un poco mas de negocios,
y fuí a la Escuela de Negocios de Stanford y estudié allí.
Y mientras estaba allí me hice amigo de una persona
llamada Pierre Omidyar, que esta aquí hoy. Y Pierre, me disculpo
por esto -- esta es una foto de la vieja época.
Y justo después de graduarme, Pierre vino a mí y --
con esta idea de ayudar a la gente
a comprar y vender cosas entre ellos, en línea.
Con la sabiduría de mi diploma de Stanford,
dije, "Pierre, que idea estúpida."
(Risas)
Y no hace falta decir que él tenía razón.
Pero a poco de eso, Pierre -- en el '96, Pierre y yo dejamos nuestros trabajos
para construir eBay como compañía. Y el resto es historia, ustedes saben.
La compañía cotizó en bolsa dos años más tarde
y es hoy una de las empresas más conocidas del mundo.
Cientos de millones de personas la usa en cientos de países, y así sigue.
Pero para mí personalmente, fue un cambio real.
Pasé de vivir en una casa con cinco amigos en Palo Alto.
y vivir de sus sobras,
a repentinamente tener todo tipo de recursos.
Y yo quería descubrir como podía
tomar la bendición de esos recursos y compartirlos con el mundo.
Y alrededor de esa época conocí a John Gardner.
que es un hombre excepcional.
Fué el arquitecto de los programa de la Gran Sociedad
bajo Lyndon Johnson en los 60s.
Y le pregunté que sentía que era lo mejor que yo podía hacer,
o cualquiera podía hacer, para hacer una diferencia
en los temas de largo plazo que enfrenta la humanidad.
Y John dijo, "Apuesta en gente buena haciendo cosas buenas.
Apuesta en gente buena haciendo cosas buenas".
Y eso realmente tuvo eco en mí.
Y comencé una fundación
para apostar por esa buena gente haciendo cosas buenas.
Estos líderes, innovadores, que no buscan ganancias personales,
que utilizan habilidades de negocios de manera muy apalancada
para resolver problemas sociales.
Gente que hoy llamamos emprendedores sociales.
Y para ponerle un rostro, gente como Mohammed Yunus,
que fundó el Grameen Bank,
que ha sacado 100 millones de personas o mas de la pobreza en todo el mundo,
ganó el premio Nobel de la Paz.
Pero también hay mucha gente que ustedes no conocen.
Gente como Ann Cotton, que comenzó un grupo llamado CAMFED en Africa
porque sentía que la educación de las niñas estaba retrasada.
Y ella lo comenzó hace como 10 años
y hoy, ella educa a más de un cuarto de millón de niñas africanas.
Y alguien como la Dra. Victoria Hale,
que comenzó la primera empresa farmacéutica del mundo, sin fines de lucro.
Y cuya primera droga combatirá la leishmaniasis visceral,
también conocida como la fiebre negra.
Y para el 2010 ella espera haber eliminado la enfermedad,
que es un verdadero flagelo en el mundo en vías de desarrollo.
Y así esto --- esto es un modo de apostar
a que buena gente hará cosas buenas.
Y mucho de esto viene junto con una filosofía de cambio
que para mí es realmente poderosa.
Es lo que llamamos, "Invierte, conecta y celebra".
Invierte -- si tu ves gente buena haciendo cosas buenas,
invierte en ellos. Invierte en sus organizaciones.
O en negocios, invierte en esta gente.
Conectándola a través de conferencias,
como TED, que trae tantas conexiones poderosas,
o a través del Foro Mundial de Emprendimiento Social
que mi fundación hace en Oxford cada año.
Y celebremoslos, contemos sus historias,
porque no solo hay buena gente haciendo buen trabajo,
pero sus historias pueden ayudar a cerrar la brecha de esperanza.
Y eso fue la última parte de la misión, la parte de celebrar,
la que realmente me puso a pensar en cuando era niño
y quería contar historias para involucrar a la gente
en esos temas que nos afectan a todos.
Y se encendió la lámpara,
que fue primero, que no necesitaba escribir yo, podía encontrar escritores.
Y luego la siguiente lámpara fue, mejor que solo escribir,
que hay de las películas y TV, para llegar a la gente de gran modo?
Y pensé en las películas que me inspiraron,
películas como "Gandhi" y "La Lista de Schindler".
Y me pregunté quién hacía ese tipo de filmes hoy.
Y no había realmente una compañía específica
que se enfocara en en interés público.
Así que en el 2003, comencé a dar vueltas por Los Angeles
para hablar de la idea de una compañía de medios pro-social
y recibí mucho estímulo.
Una de esas frases de aliento
que escuché una y otra vez era,
"Las calles de Hollywood estan llenas de cadavers de gente como tu,
que cree que va a venir a esta ciudad y hacer películas."
Y claro, también estaba la otra frase,
"La manera mas segura de volverse millonario
es empezar siendo billonario y entrar en el negocio del cine."
(Risas)
Sin inmutarme, en enero de 2004 fundé Participant Productions
con la visión de ser una empresa global de medios
enfocada en el interés público.
Y nuestra misión es producir entretenimiento
que crea e inspira cambio social.
Y no solo queremos que la gente vea nuestras películas
y digan eso fue divertido, y se olviden de ello.
Queremos que se involucren en estos asuntos.
En el 2005 lanzamos nuestra, nuestra primera tirada de películas,
"Murder Ball", "North Country", "Syriana"
y "Good Night and Good Luck".
Y muy a mi sorpresa, fueron vistas.
Terminamos con 11 nominaciones para el Oscar por esos filmes.
Y terminó siendo un año bastante bueno para este señor.
Tal vez más importante,
decenas de miles de personas se unieron a programas de apoyo
y programas activistas
que fueron creados para rodear estas películas.
Y teníamos un componente online de esto,
nuestra secta comunitaria llamada Participate.net
Pero con nuestros socios sociales como el ACLU y PBS y el
Sierra Club y la NRDC, una vez que la gente vió la película
había algo que realmente podían hacer, para hacer una diferencia.
Uno de estos filmes en particular llamado "North Country", fue realmente
un especie de fracaso de taquilla.
Pero era una película con Charlize Theron como estrella
y era sobre los derechos de las mujeres, darle poder a las mujeres,
violencia domestica, y eso.
Y lanzamos la película al mismo momento que
el congreso debatía la renovación de la Ley de Violencia Contra las Mujeres.
Y con proyecciones en el congreso y discusiones,
y con nuestros socios del sector social,
como la Organización Nacional de Mujeres (NOW),
la película recibió una amplia reputación
de haber influenciado la exitosa renovación de la Ley.
Y eso para mí, dice muchísimo, porque es la --
la pelìcula que comienza sobre una historia real.
Sobre una mujer que fue acosada, enjuició a su empleador,
llevó a un caso fundamental para la Ley de Igualdad de Oportunidades,
y la Ley de Violencia Contra las Mujeres y otras.
Y después la película sobre esta persona haciendo estas cosas,
luego llevó a esta mayor renovación.
Y así nuevamente,
volvemos a lo de apostar por buena gente haciendo cosas buenas.
Hablando de ello, nuestro TEDster colega, Al,
Vi por primera vez a Al hacer su presentación de transparencias
sobre el calentamiento global en Mayo de 2005.
Hasta ese momento pensé que sabía algo sobre calentamiento global.
Yo pensaba que era un problema a 30 o 50 años.
Y después de ver su presentacion,
se me hizo claro que el problema era mucho mas urgente.
Y así apenas terminó, me encontré con Al entre bambalinas y
con Lawrence Bender que estaba allí, y Laurie David
y Davis Guggenheim,
que manejaba los documentales de Participant en esa época.
Y con la bendición de Al, decidimos allí mismo transformarla en una película,
porque sentimos que podíamos sacar el mensaje
mucho más rápido que teniendo a Al dando la vuelta al mundo,
hablando a públicos de 100 o 200 personas por vez.
Y ustedes saben, hay otro dicho en Hollywood,
que nadie sabe nada de nada.
Y yo realmente pensé que esto iba a ser
una iniciativa de caridad que iba directo a PBS (TV pública).
Y asi que fue una gran sorpresa para todos nosotros
cuando el filme realmente capturó el interés del público,
y hoy es una vista obligatoria en colegios de Inglaterra y Escocia,
y la mayoría de Escandinavia.
Hemos enviado 50.000 DVDs a maestros de escuelas secundarias en USA
y realmente ha cambiado el debate sobre el calentamiento global.
También fue un año bastante bueno para este señor.
Ahora llamamos a Al el George Clooney del calentamiento global.
(Risas)
Y para Participant, esto es solo el comienzo.
Todo lo que hacemos mira los asuntos más importantes del mundo.
Y tenemos 10 películas en producción ahora mismo
y docenas más en desarrollo.
Voy a hablar ràpidamente de unas pocas que están viniendo.
Una es "Charlie Wilson's War," con Tom Hanks y Julia Roberts.
Y es la historia real del congresista Charlie Wilson y
como dió fondos al Taliban, para pelear con los rusos en Afganistán.
Y también estamos haciendo una película llamada "The Kite Runner",
basada en el libro "The Kite Runner", también sobre Afghanistan.
Y creemos que una vez que la gente vea estas películas
van a tener un entendimiento mucho mejor de esa parte del mundo
y del Medio Oriente en general.
Estrenamos una película llamada "The Chicago 10" en Sundance este año.
Esta basada en los que protestaron en la Convención Demócrata de 1968.
Abby Hoffman y equipo.
Y nuevamente, es una historia de un pequeño grupo de individuos
que hicieron un cambio en el mundo.
Y un documental que estamos haciendo sobre Jimmy Carter
y sus esfuerzos de paz en el Medio Oriente a través de los años.
Y en particular, hemos seguido su reciente gira por su libro
que como muchos de ustedes saben, no ha generado controversias ---
(Risas)
-- que es realmente malo para conseguir que la gente venga a ver un filme.
Para cerrar, quisiera decir que todos tienen la oportunidad
de hacer un cambio a su propio modo.
Y todas las personas en esta habitación
lo han hecho a través de su vida de negocios,
o su trabajo filantrópico o sus otros intereses.
Y una cosa que he aprendido
es que nunca hay un camino correcto para hacer un cambio.
Uno lo puede hacer como un técnico o como un financista
o como persona sin fines de lucro o como persona del entretenimiento,
pero cada uno de nosotros es todas esas cosas y mas.
Y yo creo que si hacemos esas cosas
podemos cerrar las brechas de oportunidad. Podemos cerrar las brechas de esperanza.
Y puedo imaginar que si hacemos esto,
los titulares en 10 años puede ser algo así:
"Nuevos casos de SIDA en Africa caen a cero",
"USA importa su último barril de petroleo",
(Aplauso)
-- "Israelíes y palestinos celebran
10 años de coexistencia pacífica".
(Aplauso)
Y a mi me gusta ésta, "La nieve vuelve al Kilimanjaro".
(Risas)
Y finalmente, se ofrece en eBay una presentación muy viajada
ya obsoleta, una pieza de museo -- favor contactar a Al Gore.
Y yo creo que trabajando juntos,
podemos hacer que todas estas cosas pasen.
Y quiero agradecerles a todos por tenerme hoy aquí,
Ha sido un verdadero honor. Gracias.
(Aplauso)
Oh, Gracias.